the little shop seemed to have taken the
musty worm-eaten quality of furniture
and relics it offered for sale it was an
all pervasive odor of mildew and
decaying wood dust motes world and a
shaft of sunlight as the street door
opened with the hush tinkle of a bell
above the sedate gold letters jonathan
Spruill antiques the three young people
who entered arm and arm looked as out of
place in such a shop as three children
at a board meeting the girl a vivacious
brunette with a large diamond solitaire
on her left hand linked the two men
together one at all easygoing Norse
blonde the other small wiry and dark
with sensitive features that resembled
those of the girl they stood for a
moment laughing and chattering together
but in lowered tones somewhat subdued by
the atmosphere of the old shop no no not
three rings Bob rings are so trite the
girl was protesting what we want is
something unusual right Alan something
distinctive to link us three together
always like the three musketeers
and remind us of our undying she broke
off with a stifled gasp as a stoop to
wrinkled gnome of a man a hunchback
scuttled out from the shadowy recesses
at the rear of the place there was
something spider-like about his
appearance until he smiled large
luminous brown eyes beamed upon each of
them in turn I overheard he murmured in
a mellow friendly voice that matched his
eyes you were looking for some little
memento his eyes drifted keenly to the
girl soon as your wedding day yes he
hazarded and you and your your brother
and your fiance wish to buy some antique
curio in triplicate as a bond of love
and remembrance
the trio glanced at one another jaws
dropping why yes the girl laughed you
must be psychic observation merely
observation and deduction the old
proprietor chuckled pleasantly I have
very little trade here worse luck and
much time to meditate now what did you
have in mind
three identical snuff boxes perhaps 17th
century or what about lockets
Renaissance Italian with your pictures
in each
have some that fold open in three
sections two of them could be worn as
watch fobs of course he smiled at the
two utterly unlike but congenial young
men they grinned back at him wondering
curiously among the cluttered displays
of crow's nest tables hammered brass
fire-dogs
old spinning wheels and hundred other
reminders of generations passed idly
they wandered over to a showcase of
antique silverware ornate gold and
silver sugar shells pickle Forks with
tiny demons on the handle
little salt spoons and graceful dagger
shaped butter knives the girl strolled
away by herself poking about with quiet
fascination presently her eyes fell on a
small worn black velvet case pushed half
out of sight on a shelf she leaned to
open it and called out eagerly look Oh
Alan Bob look I found some monkey spoons
she beckoned to her brother and fiance
then smiled across the shop at the old
proprietor whose sudden look of
agitation she failed to notice these are
monkey spoons aren't they mr. spool I've
never seen any with the drinking monkey
perched on the knob
it's always something stylized a fawn or
a skull these must be very old
the two men moved to her side fondly
amused at her excitement the blonde one
Bob looked at the dark one Alan and
spread his hands humorously what on
earth he drawled our monkey spoons Alan
if we're going to open that antique shop
of ours with my backing and marshes and
your experience you'll just have to
brief me on these the brother and sister
started explaining both at once
interrupting each other they gave up
laughing then suddenly mr. Spruill
stepped forward edging unobtrusively
between the three young people in the
black velvet box
monkey spoons he explained diffidently
were presented by the old Dutch Patroons
to honored guests and relatives as late
as the 17th century they were mementos
of some occasion a funeral most often as
you can see from these very fine
specimens skillfully he steered the trio
away to another showcase shutting the
black velvet box behind him with a
furtive gesture these he pointed out one
set of five are typical note the wide
shallow fluted bowl of the spoon very
thin silver bearing a hammered out
picture symbolic of funerals a man on
horseback delivering the invitations
with a churchyard in the background
these bear a likeness of Saint Michel
wear of souls on Judgment Day this one
has a picture of a mourner weeping over
a sinner re-earn her cheerful little
trinkets aren't they Bob left resting
one hand on Alan's shoulder and sliding
his other arm about his fiance's waist
you mean to say they passed out these
things at funerals like flowers at a
party not exactly mr. Sproule smiled
they were hung around the rim of the
punchbowl at the dude feast or dead
feast something like the Irishman's wake
a small silver lozenge the seal was
always welded at the center of the
handle engraved with the name of the
deceased and the dates of his birth and
death the handles are quite slender you
see they curl backwards like the end of
a violin to form the knob on which is
mounted a silver faun or a skull or or a
monkey the girl asked eagerly why monkey
spoons mr. Sproule she drifted over to
the black box again and picked up on
spoon
I've always wondered why they're called
that that the old dealer shrugged his
hump shoulders is an enigma among
antique experts one theory is that the
monkey was simply a symbolic invitation
to come and be gay at the Dead feast eat
drink and be merry you know for tomorrow
swegen der monkey or sucking the monkey
was an old dutch expression meaning to
get drunk hug Marsha's delicate nose
wrinkled and distaste I certainly
wouldn't want everybody getting soused
at my funeral they'll just have to sit
around and cry soberly or they'll get no
monkey spoons from me remember
that now Bob she laughed and planted a
kiss on her fiance's cheek hush her
brother the more sensitive of the two
men shuddered visibly Marcia don't be so
morbid people shouldn't joke about whose
morbid the girl laughed more gaily
winking at Bob Oh Alan you're a [ __ ] do
come and look at these darling monkey
spoons over here
those with the drinking monkeys are very
rare are they mr. Sproule there are only
three of these her face lighted up and
she whirled about at a sudden idea why
don't we choose these for our keepsakes
I could have mine made into a scarf pin
Bob yours and Alan's could be watch fobs
or you could have them welded on silver
cigarette cases some old Dutchman's
funeral spoons wouldn't that just be too
gruesome and clever and she added
eagerly we can call our antique shop the
three spoons and people will drop in by
the droves just to ask us why Bob
darling please buy them her fiance
grinned at her fondly winked at her
discomforted brother and reached for his
checkbook with a light shrug all right
my precious all right anything your
foolish little heart desires but funeral
spoons he roared with amusement what a
gift from the groom to the bride
mr. Spruill how much are you asking for
he broke off caught by the expression on
the face of the hunchbacked antique
dealer mr. sprue looked frightened there
was no mistaking that quiver about his
mouth or the agitation in his kindly old
eyes wouldn't she prefer something less
expensive he blurted those particular
spoons are almost a collector's item
besides he added in an oddly loud tone
they're not mine to sell really they're
not mine he emphasized the words
strangely and glanced toward the dark
rear of the shop as though he were
speaking for the benefit of some
skulking eavesdropper whom they could
not see the former owner he lowered his
voice again an apology was in mrs.
Haversham an elderly widow her heirs
have not yet been located she died
without a will about a month ago shortly
after buying the set of four monkey
spoons at an auction she kept one spoon
and left three of them with me to sell
for her at a profit merely as her agent
he emphasized sharply with another odd
glance toward a particularly dark corner
she kept 1/4 spoon not wanting to part
with her entire collection she was
asphyxiated in her garage he added with
apparent irrelevance carbon monoxide gas
from her car an accidental death of
course he said quickly again with that
nervous glance into the shadows the girl
Marcia her fiance Bob and her brother
Alan looked at one another significantly
the old hunchback was certainly peculiar
to say the least a borderline mental
case Bob's raised eyebrows suggested
with a glance that his fiance's
disappointed expression he became brisk
and businesslike well you have the legal
right to sell the spoons though and
collect your commission he pointed out
shrewdly how much $500 mr. Sproule
murmured then added with a manner of
pleading that's exorbitant of course and
I can find you something much more
attractive for the price exorbitant you
can say that again
for three little spoons the blond young
man whistled good-humoredly but uncapped
his fountain pen that's $500 a piece mr.
Sproule said hurriedly
for each spoon now I'm sure you wouldn't
care to pay so much for a a whim let me
just show you Bob set his jaw stubbornly
giving the old dealer an oblique look
mr. Sproule don't you want to make this
sale look if you're trying to run up the
price he snapped
just because my fiance has taken such a
fancy to he broke off grinned abruptly
and spread his hands and rueful defeat
all right you old pirate fifteen hundred
it is he smiled indulgently at the girl
beside him he was shaking her head
violently if it's something you really
want darling you shall have it
old mr. Sproles sighed deeply with a
tone of resignation rather than of
satisfaction the price he said heavily
is five hundred for the set if you
insist on buying it but I must tell you
this although I am sure you young people
will laugh at me or perhaps be even more
intrigued by these these devilish spoons
you see they mr. Sproule gulped they're
supposed to be cursed the two men did
laugh but the girl's face lit up she
clapped her hands as pleased as a child
with its first jack-o'-lantern Oh a
curse how marvelous why didn't you tell
us before
now I simply must have them the old
hunchback nodded and shrugged as I
predicted he murmured
then doggedly the spoons are mementos of
the funeral of an old Dutch patroon
Skylar van Groot --n you'll see his name
on the seals who owned and tenant farmed
about half of the Connecticut Valley in
the 1600s mrs. Haversham had an old
Dutch diary written by one of his
ancestors I was able to translate only a
few pages when I called at her home but
it seems there were thirteen spoons
originally rather a significant unlucky
number as the patroon was secretly
murdered by friends and relatives who
would inherit his estate one by one the
story goes he caused six guilty ones to
die exactly as he himself had died the
remaining owners of the monkey spoons
became frightened finally and gave
theirs away thereby escaping his
vengeance but but anybody who owns the
spoons inherits the curse is that it
Marsha cried delightedly Alan isn't it
exciting Oh Bob do give mr. sprue a
check before somebody comes in and buys
our haunted spoons right out from under
our noses the antique dealer looked at
her and sighed he saw the girl's brother
bite his lips frowning but the blond
young man grinned at his fiancee and
wrote out a check for the three monkey
spoons opening the black velvet box he
presented one of the spoons to Marcia
with an exaggerated bow the second he
gave to Alan holding it over his wrist
like a proffered rapier the third spoon
he thrust carelessly into the pocket of
his tweed coat then laughing at his
horseplay Marcia offered an arm to each
of the two young men and they marched
out together whistling and harmony into
the sunlit Street behind them old mr.
Spruill although he was not a very
devout Catholic crossed himself he ran a
finger around under his collar and
inhaled noisily aware all at once of the
extreme stuffiness of his little shop it
was unusually close in here today he
thought almost stifling he scurried to a
window and flung it open gulping in
lungfuls of cool autumn air as if for
some reason he found it terribly hard to
breathe
it was almost closing time about a week
later when the Bell over his door
tinkled again and two of the attractive
young threesome walked into his shop
mister Spruill scuttled forward to meet
them beaming in recognition but his
smile faded at the sight of the grim
expression on the blonde man's face and
the stunned swollen eyed look of the
pretty girl she had been crying
the older dealer saw and Bob her fiance
was tight-lipped and cold with anger yes
mr. Sproule murmured hesitantly you were
not satisfied with your purchase an odd
look of Hope leaped into his eyes you
wish to return the spoons perhaps of
course I shall be glad to refund yer for
an answer the blonde young man thrust
one of the delicate little monkey spoons
under his nose pointing to the tiny
silver seal welded at the center of the
handle is this your idea of a joke he
snapped the antique dealer blinked and
putting on an old-fashioned pair of
square lens spectacles peered at the
spoon the blood slowly from his face I
don't understand he stammered when I
sold them to you the inscriptions read
Schuyler van Groot n' born august third
1586 died June 816 31 but now now it
reads Alan Fentress born September 14
1924 died November 3rd 1949 why he broke
off that's yesterday a sob burst from
the girl and she buried her face against
her fiance's shoulder weeping wildly Bob
glared at mr. spruill yes he said
harshly and Alan was drowned yesterday
November 3rd 1949 the death date
engraved on that damned how the devil
did you get hold of Alan's spoon he
towered over the old [ __ ] threatening
Lee you sadistic old you took that seal
off didn't you and welded the new one on
just to to stir up some freak publicity
and boom trade for your crummy little
shop but Alan he ground out through
clenched teeth why did you have to pick
on Alan because you knew he was moody
and susceptible to suggestion because
you knew he'd brood over your little
hoax not telling us his painting wasn't
going well lately so you thought it
would be a cinch to drive him to suicide
out there in the lake yesterday he he
just stopped swimming and went under
when I got his clothes from the locker
room I found this damn spoon you changed
like a death sentence mr. Sproule gasped
looking first at the dead youth angry
friend then at his grieving sister
oh no he protested My dear young people
you surely don't accuse me of you're
upset who wouldn't be it's the curse he
said quietly remember I did my best to
warn you to plant your story you mean
the young man snarled glaring at him
furiously he led the girl toward the
door come on darling I might have known
we'd get no satisfaction out of this
this cold-blooded old ghoul but let me
tell you he threw back furiously at the
antique dealer when I locate the
engraver who changed that inscription or
find out how you learned Alan's
birthdate I'll come back here and kill
you the door slammed with an agitated
jingle of the little Bell
mr. Spruill stood for a moment wringing
his hands miserably he had liked those
three light-hearted young people on
sight and would not for the world have
wished harm to befall any of them but
there were forces a crippled old man
could not combat forces older than any
item in his musty little shop older than
logic older than time oh dear heaven the
hunchback moaned why didn't I tell them
to give those other two spoons away melt
them down bury them anything if that
diary had only told how van Groot and
I'd perhaps I could have warned them to
avoid but there were only hints the
writer never did come out and say but
that young man is intelligent perhaps he
could come to some conclusion that I've
missed he turned and ran for the
telephone directory leafing through it
hastily to find the names Fentress or
Milam the signature on the young man's
check for an hour he clung to the phone
calling every Fentress and Milam in the
book but there was no Robert Milam mr.
Spruill tried the hotels than the
funeral homes to trace the dead brother
Alan finally he hung up defeated
concluding that they were all from out
of town
he sat staring at the telephone then
wringing his wrinkled old hands and the
helpless anguish of one who can only
wait wait for disaster but the period of
waiting was not long three days later
just at noon the door bell tinkled again
mr. sprue looked up from a six branched
candelabra he was polishing to see a
disheveled figure swaying a few feet
from him it was Bob Milam his face drawn
and covered with a stubble of beard his
eyes bloodshot and puffy from drinking
in his hand he held an ugly little
automatic mr. Spruill caught his breath
and stood very still then despite his
own fear he burst out oh my poor young
friend the second spoon your fiancee the
blond man's mouth twisted with pain and
bitterness for reply he flung another
one of the monkey spoons at the old
dealers feet mr. Sproles stooped to pick
it up he paled and nodded the tiny oval
seal on the handle was engraved to read
Marcia Fentress born April 17 1927 died
November 6th 1949 at the old man's nod
Bob's eyes narrowed
he said not a word but the ominous click
of the safety catch on his gun was
eloquent enough yet there was more pity
than terror in mr. Sproles face Oh his
murmur of shocked sympathy had a genuine
ring
how did she my fiance the young man
grated bitterly was terribly
grief-stricken at her brother's death
you figured on that too didn't you you
insane twisted his voice broke on a sob
of impotent rage Alan and Marcia were
inseparable we three were in fact Marcia
couldn't sleep so last night she took a
big dose of sleeping pills he gulped
then plunged on miserably while she was
drugged a very large beauty pillow on
her bed fell over her face somehow it
wasn't the sleeping pills she smothered
to death
the coroner called it an accident he
lashed out but I call it murder
you murdered Alan too I can't prove it
but I surely as hell can with a sob he
leveled the gun at the old antique
dealers heart his mouth working with
hate and grief at the sight of his
tortured young face mr. Spruill dabbed
at his eyes oblivious to his own danger
my poor unfortunate young friend he
murmured pityingly you can't believe I
would cause such tragedy for a few
paltry dollars I did not change those
seals but I cannot hope to persuade
anyone as matter of fact as yourself to
believe in the supernatural
the diary recounts that when each guest
at van Groot instead feasts died their
spoons changed to mrs. Haversham Seale
altered also the lawyer found it later
among her effects but assumed it to be
the grim jest of some House servant Bob
Milam snorted derisively but the
murderous anger in his eyes edie
slowly and the gun in his hand wavered
you're insane he said heavily maybe you
don't even realize you changed those
seals maybe your twisted mind really
believes all that silly guff about some
old Dutchman who his shoulders slumped
all at once he swayed passing one hand
over his bleary eyes the gun and his
other hand clattered to the floor
suddenly he snatched the monkey spoon
and flung it down the furnace grating
insane he mumbled I can't shoot a crazy
crippled old man in cold blood but why
did you do it he groaned staring at the
hunchback why mister Spruill why my best
friend and then my fiance I gladly have
signed over my whole bank account to you
if it was money you owe please the
antique dealer cried out in despair you
must believe that I had no pardon I
tried to phone you to warn you tried to
figure out the manner of death so you
can avoid but they all died so
differently mrs. Haversham asphyxiated
your friend drowned and your lovely
fiancee the old man's eyes widened
suddenly ah now I understand it's true
it all ties together listen to me
Bob Milam had turned unsteadily toward
the door but mr. Spruill sidled after
him like a small persistent crab and
seized him by the arm no wait you must
listen he gasped the diary mentioned
that Skylar van Groot Anu as subject to
sleeping fits a cataleptic his intimate
friends and relatives must have known
that but they wait he begged your monkey
spoon where is it you must give it away
at once the old dealer insisted
excitedly to some impersonal agency the
scrap metal drive yes that's it get it
out of your possession or you two will
so much hate such hunger for revenge
hovers about them like a piece of metal
that's been magnetized they can actually
draw disaster to anyone who but at that
moment the blonde young man jerked his
arm loose and plunged out into the
street wanting only to get away from
this crazy old man who had caused him so
much grief in the space of a few short
days mr. Sproule pattered after him
calling excitedly for him to wait but by
the time he reached the curb
Bob Milam had whistled down a passing
cab and was climbing into it the old
hunchback hurried to the curb and
strained to catch the address but the
young man was only telling the driver
wearily drive around just drive anywhere
I don't care the antique dealers arms
dropped to his sides limply in defeat he
watched the taxi speed out of sight then
turned slowly and walked slowly
thoughtfully back into his shop the
evening paper left under his door as
usual carried the story a taxi was
ambling along a hundred and eighty
seventh Street where wreckers were busy
raising an old warehouse somehow the
dynamite charge went off sooner than was
intended and a crumbling wall of bricks
and mortar fell on the cab as it passed
the cabbie managed to dig his way out
but the single passenger an intoxicated
young man identified as one Robert Milam
of New Jersey could not be pulled out of
the wreckage for almost an hour he was
dead when frantic workmen did finally
reach him not crushed but trapped
without air in the rear seat of the taxi
cab and in his pocket the police found a
peculiar looking spoon inscribed with
his name the date of his birth and the
very date of his death mr. Sproule
finished reading then took off his
square lenses and polished them with a
hand that trembled there was nothing he
mused philosophically really nothing at
all that he could have done to save
those three nice young people who had
all three died the same way fighting for
breath smothered to death by one agency
or another just exactly as mrs.
Haversham had died in her exhaust filled
garage and just as centuries ago an old
Dutch patroon once skyler van Groot n'
clawing and screaming and gasping for
breath in his coffin awakened from one
of his cataleptic trances to find that
his greedy heirs had deliberately buried
him alive it has been 10 years since my
uncle Philip Westerley disappeared many
theories have been advanced as to why
and how he vanished so strangely and so
completely many have wondered why a man
should vanish and leave nothing behind
him but a smashed mirror and none of
these theories or wild imaginings are
half so fantastic as the story I
gathered from the diary which some whim
prompted him to keep but first a word
about philip westerly he was a wealthy
man and also a cruel selfish man his
wealth was attributed to the same
cruelty and selfishness he also had many
whims one of them was keeping a diary
another was his love for mirrors he was
handsome in a cruel sort of way and
almost effeminate and is liking to stand
before them and admire himself this
eccentricity was borne out by the fact
that covering one whole side of his room
was a mirror of gigantic size the same
mirror that is linked with his
disappearance but read the excerpts from
the diary of Philip West early August
3rd afternoon Billings asked for an
extension on that note today but I saw
no reason why I should grant him any
such thing when I told him this he began
cursing me in a frightful manner he said
I was cruel and that someday I would be
called to account for the way I treated
people
I laughed outright at this but at the
same time I felt a vague sense of
uneasiness which even yet I have not
dispelled
night a remarkable thing has happened I
had gone to my room to dress for dinner
and I was standing before the mirror
tying my tie I had begun the usual
procedure that one follows when I
noticed that no such action was recorded
in the mirror true there was my
reflection in the glass but it followed
none of the movements that I made it was
immobile I extended my hand to touch the
reflection and encountered nothing but
the polished surface of the mirror then
I noticed a truly remarkable thing the
reflection in the mirror
wore no tie I stepped back aghast was
this an illusion had my mind and vision
been affected by some malady that I was
not aware of impossible then I regarded
the reflection with a more careful
scrutiny there were a number of
differences between it and myself for
one thing at Waris stubby growth of
beard on its face I was positive that I
had visited the barber that very day and
passed my hand across my chin to verify
this it encountered nothing but smooth
skin the lips of the man in the mirror
drooped in a display of gnarled yellow
fangs while my own bared nothing but two
rows of gleaming well-cared-for teeth I
was filled simultaneously with a feeling
of disgust and fear and looked for
further discrepancies I found them the
feet and hands were abnormally large and
the clothing of the thing was old baggy
and covered with filth I dared not stay
longer I tied the tie as best I could
and descended hurriedly to dinner
August 4th morning I awoke feeling jaded
and tired my friend in the mirror is
still with me ordinarily the reflection
of myself in bed is caught in the mirror
but not so this morning instead I saw
that the dweller within had liked myself
than having a night's rest I hope he
slept better than I did for my own night
was a series of fitful restless tossings
good morning I said rising
when I moved he moved as I advanced
toward the mirror he drew closer to me I
stopped and surveyed him he resembled me
only remotely I hope I smiled and he
responded with a wolfish twist of his
mouth I extended my hand as if I wanted
to shake hands with him but he drew back
as if from fire I can't understand the
terror which he holds for me
I try not to show my fear in front of
him but I feel that animal like he
senses it I refer to the reflection as
he him or it for I cannot bring myself
to admit that the thing in the mirror is
my reflection but I scarcely dare write
what I do believe it to be I have always
been skeptical about such things as soul
but when I look into the mirror god help
me night I am spending much time in my
room now I've spent most of the day here
this thing is beginning to hold a morbid
fascination for me I can't stay away for
any length of time I wish I could my
wife is beginning to worry about me she
says I look pale she tells me I need a
rest a long rest if I could only confide
in her in any one but I can't I must
fight and wait this out alone
August 5th there has been little or no
change in our relationship he still
remains aloof today my wife came to my
room to see how I was feeling she stood
in such a position that looking into the
mirror was unavoidable she stood before
the mirror arranging her hair she
noticed nothing out of the ordinary but
he was still there damn him he was still
there and this time he snarled and
triumph at me one other remarkable thing
my wife hadn't seen the thing there in
the mirror but neither had I seen her
reflection it was the same with Peter my
valet and Anna the maid Anna would have
dusted the mirror had I not stopped her
I must take no chances a close scrutiny
might reveal him to them and they must
not know they must not know
August 6 three days three days of hell
that's what it's been since I discovered
that damned thing how he tortures me he
has begun to mock me when he thinks he
has given an extraordinarily clever
impersonation he shakes with laughter I
can't hear him laughs but I see him and
that's worse I can't stand it much
longer
August 7th we never know how much we can
stand until we go through some ordeal
such as I am now undergoing but I feel
that my nerve is near the breaking point
I have locked the door of my room Anna
leaves a tray outside my door sometimes
I eat the food she brings but more often
I don't
my wife begs me to let her in but I tell
her to go away I'm afraid to tell her
I'm afraid to tell anyone I know what
they do with people who have
hallucinations no I can't tell neither
can I leave God knows why but I can't
August 8 it was the day before yesterday
that I mentioned his mocking me today I
tremble at the thought he is beginning
to resemble me this morning I looked in
the mirror and discovered that he had
discarded his rags and was now dressed
in one of my suits I ran to the Wardrobe
and discovered his clothes hanging where
mine had been I turned and faced him he
laughed and pointed toward my hands and
feet they were bloated beyond
recognition
I dare not guess how far this change has
gone I can write no more today August
9th the change is complete
he looks more like me than I do myself
he has grown more cruel with the change
he stalks me with my ugliness finally I
could stand it no longer I fled from the
room at last I found the thing I was
looking for a mirror when I came face to
face with what I now AM I nearly
collapsed yes he has taken my form God
pity me I've taken his
i slunk back to the room in horror back
to his laughter and the hell that is now
my existence
god knows what tomorrow will bring
august 10th
seven days since that devil has been in
the mirror i prayed to god that it may
be the last it will I know it will he in
the mirror senses it too I see the look
of apprehension in his eyes damn him
it's my turn to snarl in triumph now for
when I lay down this pen for the last
time perhaps I shall leap through the
mirror and he exists only in the mirror
god help me I am laying down my pen the
taxi drove off leaving Foster on the
hottest and lawn surrounded by suitcases
Foster was thinking it more than merely
odd that Barclay for whose coaching he
had come prepared to spend a month had
not met him as planned he tried the
screen door it was hooked inside hello
and there he hailed hopefully there was
no response the hottest and firmly
drenched in a torpid lethargy for which
it was obvious more than the July heat
must be responsible within the house no
one stirred on the surrounding fields
no one was abroad even the usual sounds
of the farm animals were hushed Foster
was unpleasantly affected surely the
entire household had not gone to meet
his train and somehow missed it he
carried his traps to the stoop crossed
the yard to the barnyard and called out
again he knew of old where Barclays
studio was so he set off down the path
toward the grateful shade of the woods
the gray stone walls of the old building
soon glinted through the tree trunks and
heavy foliage a strong conviction
possessed foster that Barclay was not
within in fact he found the studio door
padlocked he noted that the West window
was rudely boarded up he walked around
the studio to the north
here the trees had been cut down and the
studio wall was entirely of glass he
peered in with deepening curiosity but
apart from the usual litter of easels
painting paraphernalia and accessories
canvases and clothes set rows against
the walls his attention was almost
immediately drawn to a painting propped
against the south wall were the full
light from the opposite windows poured
in revealingly how odd
Foster muttered puzzled that doesn't
look like Barclays work and he would
never have let a student perpetrate such
a monstrosity of lion and crude colour
he pressed his face to the glass cupping
it against the outside light that old
man Foster said aloud amazed
maybe crudely done but he's also
absolutely horrible his hands their dead
hands bloodless waxen something about
the way he's sitting there drooping is
if he hadn't the strength to sit erect
and was being held by something
something without that you can't see I
don't like the thing it's ugly there's
something wrong with it he said this
last with conviction and as he exclaimed
became aware of another gaze fixed upon
himself he snapped upright and wheeled
quickly waiting patiently for him to
finish his examination of the studio's
interior stood a man and patched stained
blue overalls
well snapped Foster sharply a bit taken
aback mr. Barclays at the house sir your
mr. Foster I'm Mulcahy hottest uns hired
man Foster nodded all right I'm coming
how did Mr Barclay come to miss my train
we was all down at the police station
sir
Mulcahy fell in behind him police
station at good Foster what's been going
on here I found mr. Oki dead in the
studio this morning sir
what foster world and confronted the
Irishman there's something wrong in
there sir
I saw blood on the old Devil's beard the
man's voice quavered snap out of it
Mulcahy are you referring to that
picture I am that sir
blood on the old man's beard ridiculous
I saw none
Mulcahy insisted stubbornly blood it was
sir and the poor young man's was all
drained out of him
foster stiffened too deep attention ha
this sounds intriguing blood on the old
man's beard and dripping from his dead
finger sir and not one drop left in the
corpse blood all over the damned old
Devils whiskers and his dead finger sir
Mary Mother Mulcahy crossed himself with
pious haste who did that painting Foster
demanded turning again toward the house
a man by the name of Silva he's actually
a cabinetmaker but he got to thinking he
could paint so he made that beauty back
there
devil fly away with him he sure can't
paint muttered foster cryptically he's
mixing something with his paint that
only Devils from the pit can give him
the Irishman declared darkly he
hesitated then rushed on sir the night
before the poor lad was murdered there
was a fine canvas of mr. Barclays cut
into ribbons and mr. Okies prized
picture the same what might that mean
along with the poor lads being killed
the next night and Silva only getting
honorable mention last week where he was
looking for first prize looks as if
Silva had a motive declared foster as
they walked into the barnyard life was
stirring normally about the farm now as
if a band of enchanted silence had been
lifted Foster could see Barclays bulky
body leaning over the suitcases on the
front stoop he hailed his friend then
asked Mulcahy hastily what did the
police say any of us might have done it
sir but the studio was locked from the
inside and there's no motive they can't
figure out where the poor lads blood
went sir the back of the simple words
pushed to dark significance of terrible
things looks as if there's more here
than appears on the surface right you
are sir from now on Todd Mulcahy wears a
blessed medal next is Hyde day and night
Foster met Barclays welcoming hand with
a heartening grip sorry to have missed
you Foster but this ghastly tragedy has
dislocated all plans I was fond of the
boy groaned Barclay his face working he
had a gift had Harry I was looking
forward to what he would do with colour
in the not far future and now his voice
broke where's my room Barclay foster
gathered up his bags and followed the
other painter up the front stairs both
men lighted
rats in silence Barclay stared
abstractedly from the window while
foster unpacked rapidly puffing clouds
of smoke about himself as he tossed
shirts underwear ties into the open
bureau of drawers I want to know how
Silva's painting got into your studio he
said at last with an air of relief as he
finished his work so you're taking that
attitude Barclay asked his eyes heavy
Foster did not attempt to evade the
implied issue anybody but a crass
materialistic jackass would he responded
quietly I didn't know you went in for
that sort of thing I've no time for
anything but painting just making a
living takes most of my time these days
foster the younger man's eyes snapped a
very little suffices for me I'm too
fascinated with studying the truths
underlying the illusions of material
existence not that I've gotten very far
but what I know I know then perhaps you
can say what's unnatural about poor
Harry's death I know there's something
wrong about it something wrong
echoed the younger man thoughtfully yes
there's something wrong and uncanny
about this lads death as to it being
unnatural there are many strange and
little-known laws operating along lines
so new to us he broke off there his
expression clearing as if an
illuminating idea had suddenly clarified
the situation for him
I believe the poor chaps death is due to
an extremely interesting example of the
transference of an evil will to power
Barclay wheeled from the window saying
abruptly I didn't tell the police what I
felt lay behind this tragedy
I have no hankering to live in an insane
asylum now I have a faint hope that you
may be able to appreciate the
strangeness of my experience
listen Manuel Silva settled here a few
years ago and has been doing well as a
cabinetmaker
recently he learned that I got from $300
up for a canvas he thought this an easy
way to get rich but I refused to teach
him you know I never take any but
advanced students have decided promised
my refusal roused Silva's furious
resentment
I've instituted an annual art exhibit in
town silver entered three canvases to
force my hand they were rather terrible
one was a blacksmith dark sullen
sinister he was hammering viciously at
what appeared to be a battered crucifix
another was a farmer slaughtering a
wretched hog that somehow looked like a
naked man the butcher's face wore a too
realistic grin of sadistic enjoyment as
he wielded his bloody knife the third
the third was the painting you've just
seen in my studio Harry's entry took
first prize this was inevitable
I felt inclined to encourage a couple of
young local artists so gave them
honorable mention not to slight Silva's
pride I included him the night before
the canvases were removed Harry and I
were in the gallery and he pointed out
that someone had deliberately cut the
Honorable Mention ribbon on silva's
canvas so that it hung in dangling
strips odd that a your opening vistas
replied foster lighting another
cigarette from the one he had been
smoking you are absorbing Lee
interesting I criticized Silva's
painting observing that Harry was right
when he said it gave him the jitters but
that in just that degree it possessed a
touch of wild genius Harry pronounced it
ghastly to paint a hunched up old man as
dead as a doornail his hands frightful
decomposing yet sitting up there Oh
Silva's colors were crude his drawing
distorted just how it would be difficult
to say but wrong you understand wrong I
said I dare not encourage Silva because
of a very strange quality in his work
that's something wrong and then we both
nearly jumped out of our skins for in
the dusk behind us someone broke into an
ugly chuckle and we turned to see a dark
figure slouching out it was Silva and I
realized that he'd heard me pronounced
him an evil genius Harry made light of
my compunctions but I was disturbed we
confronted the old man in the painting
once more
as Twilight gained the room a murky dusk
seemed creeping into the very canvas its
shadows deepened the old man merged into
his dark background all but his pallid
face his greyish beard the wax and
fingers dropping over his angular knees
it was wrong entirely wrong and then all
at once Harry twitched my sleeve and
exclaimed let's get out of here and we
turned and plunged into the street
stricken by some subtle panics so
obsessing that it was not until we were
back at the hottest and farm that we
realized how foolish and unreasonable
had been our flight foster lighted
another cigarette
we went sketching next day Berkeley went
on and hottest industy oh that night he
told me that Silva had sent me one of
his for a gift so Harry and I went down
to see which one we lighted candles and
really we got a nasty shock the
flickering inadequate candlelight made
that old man appear more than ever an
entity with a horrid existence
independent of his painted presentment
Harry said my god in a kind of comic
dismay I knew instinctively that Silva
was up to no good he bore me malice his
very gift seemed to convey dire menace
in the pale candlelight the old man's
beard appeared to rustle stiffly as if
his lips were parting under its bushy
shelter of course I couldn't see
anything but I felt that I was seeing a
pale dead tongue flicked moisture over
dry dead lips that must have been an odd
sensation said foster as he expelled a
thick cloud of smoke you make it very
clear yes well there's more of it foster
okie and I went over our canvases to
check on their return in good condition
we were satisfied just remember this
point will you
we padlocks the studio door and went off
to bed when we went in next morning the
padlock was undisturbed and all the
windows locked on the inside but one of
my best canvases had been slit into
ribbons and Harry's witcha taken first
prize was completely demolished even the
frame that last act of vandalism made me
feel bad I've been sure the boy could
cash in on his work and he needed the
money he took it like a Spartan but he
told me he was going to sleep in the
studio that night for he felt sure that
Silva had done the day
I agreed although I couldn't figure out
how Silva could have gotten inside so
last night I left the boy there he said
he was going to hang something over the
old man's god-awful face I offered to
stay with him but he wouldn't have it
this morning
Barclay broke down turning back to the
window with a suspicious gulp Mulcahy
told me foster hastened to say lighting
another cigarette it was ghastly foster
Mulcahy was howling blood at every jump
he took blood he yelled on the old man's
beard hmm how about the coroner hair
he'd been dead for hours finger marks on
his throat every drop of blood drained
from his body Barclay said with slow
emphasis Mulcahy had seen him through
the North windows I had to break the
West window to get in the coroner said
at first that he'd had a fit but finally
decided he'd been killed by a person
unknown about the blood queried Foster
Mulcahy was right about it Foster I saw
it too it's not there now Foster
declared Barclay nodded
that's another strange thing when I
rushed over I found poor Harry sprawling
on the floor his body all twisted in a
grotesque gruesome position and so
terribly white as I threw myself on the
floor beside him something struck upon
my inner ear it was a sound but such a
sound even as I heard it I knew I was
hearing what could not be apprehended
physically I sprang to my feet and
confronted Silva's hideous canvas god it
was horrible he shuddered at the bare
recollection the painted old man sat
there motionless but it was a sinister
restraint foster I stared stricken by a
horror that affected me with nausea for
I saw then that someone had smeared that
ancients deathly pallor with crimson
that crawled down the painted graybeard
the dead hands that hung over the
angular knees were dripping every pallid
fingertip with blood blood foster how do
you know it was blood Foster demanded
sharply
I touched it whispered the old man
distastefully and then foster prompted
not on gently a ghastly thing came to
pass I did not see it I felt rather than
saw I became aware with that inner sense
of the movement of one of the old man's
painted arms
it lifted with the jerking unevenness of
an automaton and passed across the
stained graybeard I say it moved
I felt it move yet at the same time I
was aware that it was only painted hence
incapable of movement it was as
something else behind it that actually
moved I find it almost impossible to
clarify my intuitions Barclay deprecated
despairingly other than to say that
while the painted figure did not stir I
was yet inwardly aware that it lifted
one arm and wiped away the crimson from
its beard then it reached out on either
side to drag off that horrible drip from
its waxen fingertips against the painted
grass that reddened under them god it
was the more horrible because although
the figure did not show movement to my
straining eyes yet I saw the Crimson
lifeblood of poor Harry disappearing
from the canvas as those movements which
I felt rather than saw took place of
course this explanation is inadequate he
finished foster pushed the consumed tip
of his cigarette to the fresh one he was
holding between his thin lips a cloud of
blue smoke enveloped him out of which
his voice pronounced decidedly not
inadequate my dear fellow on the
contrary it is very enlightening so
clear that I believe we may yet punish
the murderer of that poor lad Barclays
dreamy eyes burned with sudden fire I'd
give a year of my life to accomplish
that he exclaimed fiercely I hardly
think so much will be required but you
may have to sacrifice one or two of your
canvases we better get the rest of Okies
work over here and Silva must learn that
you were taking steps to protect Harry's
work and your own he must be informed
that tomorrow night you yourself will
sleep in the studio that will bring him
foster predicted darkly you agree that
it's Silva cried Barclay in relief I've
no doubt of it but not improperly a
persona he's projecting his astral body
through that hideous old man and he's
already made a grave error what do you
mean he's permitted himself to save her
human blood hence he cannot be permitted
to continue
he's dangerous now he will be yet more
so unless checked I propose to do this
in the only permanent way possible
we have no proof of his presence in the
studio foster who would believe the
intangible evidence of my experience no
one ordinarily Foster agreed adding
quickly but I believe and there is
another person who will not only believe
but will furnish me with the means of
putting a stop to Silva's murderous
proclivities without disturbing the
authorities unduly he finished dryly
wouldn't it be wise to return that
picture to Silva or cut it to bits and
burn it suggested Barclay uneasily later
said foster queerly you see Silva has
somehow learned how to transfer his will
for evil to that creature of his own
making it is through that same creation
that we must reach him and stop his
criminal career before it is too late
Barclay side you speak as if you knew
what you were talking about Foster I
can't just understand you but I feel
that you were somehow right what do you
wish done get Mulcahy or hottest in' to
clear out all Okies canvases leave only
a couple of your own that you don't
particularly care about so as not to
stir Silva's suspicions overly he'll
imagine your exhibiting then have
hottest ins step in and tell Silva what
happened to the canvases in the studio
and ask him to have his moved out of
harm's way that will appear a kindly
impulse on your part and he will reply
that he'll send for his canvas in a
couple of days
he'll figure on polishing you off by
then finished Foster callously agreeable
thought that side the older painter
now you're going to lend me your
roadster I'll be back tomorrow afternoon
at the latest be sure Silva is given to
understand that tomorrow night you'll be
sleeping in the studio under no
circumstances however venture in there
tonight Foster warned gravely tonight
Silva or whatever wakens in the studio
under the stimulus of his evil purpose
may have free play but tomorrow night
tomorrow night I shall be there not you
I won't permit you're getting into a
nasty situation foster this isn't your
affair after all
Harry was my protege it's up to me are
you prepared to give effective battle to
a painted demon Barclay Foster's laugh
was incredulous can you through that
painted thing silence forever the
intangible distant malefactor you can do
such things said Barclays hushed murmur
I shall know how to before I return
tomorrow afternoon but how I'm going to
someone who knows I shall demand the
secret she will yield it I'm certain I'm
going to see Gwen Cara Dorne
where have I heard that name puzzled
Barclay possibly in connection with her
published brochures her reality of the
abstract is fairly well known it's
discussed everywhere quite lately
sidebar clay I seem to remember it
vaguely now pursued foster briskly how
about your car it was dusk when foster
returned on the following day the
seriousness and abstraction that wove a
cloak about him struck Barclays curious
inquiries into silence a certain high
air about the younger artists forbade
imperiously any break upon that lofty
mood Foster's first query was had Silva
been duly informed of the occupation of
the studio that night he knows he told
hottest in that he would call for his
unappreciated masterpiece in a couple of
days the words were significantly
emphasized I rather fancied he'd say
that he knows you'll be there tonight
hottest until damn if there were any
further trouble I'd sleep there from
tonight on to protect his painting
excellent
foster rubbed his hands together and
blew a cloud of thick smoke from the
cigarette in one corner of his mouth and
was there any yes last night the two
canvases I had left were demolished good
he'll be expecting you to sleep there
tonight let's have supper then I'll run
into town and fetch miss Cara Dorne she
insists upon coming out the time was too
brief to prepare me to handle the
situation single-handed that's
extraordinarily kind of her foster but
if she is to be at the studio tonight
why not I Barkley insisted she would
have handled it alone only that she
foster broke off suddenly looking
apologetic sorry I can't be more
explicit but she bans discussion of
herself unless she decides to come out
into the open which she rarely does
she's well wait until you meet her if
she permits it foster broke off in a
kind of embarrassment you'll understand
then but believe me she is worthy the
highest respect and admiration a human
being could expect foster did not have
to drive to town between dusk and dark a
shining dark blue car with a special
delivery body slipped into the driveway
from the limousine like front to
uniformed men alighted and walked to the
rear of the car there were wide doors
there which they proceeded to open they
withdrew with the utmost care a strange
anachronism a blue and black and gold
decorated sedan chair small and delicate
they placed themselves between the
shafts and started toward the farmhouse
foster exclaimed and sprang down the
steps to meet that odd equipping he bent
over what was obviously an extended hand
white in the dusk barclays staring saw
the young artist touch his lips to those
extended fingers a child's high shrilly
sweet voice gave an order and the chair
bearers carried the sedan chair toward
the barnyard foster followed calling
back as he went
see you tomorrow morning Barclay with
that he disappeared after the chair into
the soft darkness beyond the barnyard
Barclay felt that he could not sleep he
was intensely irritated that Gwen Cara
Dorne should have sent a child to take
her place
and what he felt must be a post of
danger he went down to the shining
automobile and walked around it with
curiosity the rear doors had been closed
and nothing marked it is out of the
ordinary save perhaps the expensive type
of shock absorbers for a delivery body
and of course what looked very like a
periscope set in the top as much out of
place as was a modern child in a sedan
chair he sat at his window fell asleep
there in his chair and did not waken
until mrs. hottest intact at his door
calling that mr. foster and the little
girl had returned she volunteered that
the little girl was a perfect little
French doll Barclay took the stairs
three at a stride in the hall Foster sat
on a Hasek which brought his face
slightly below the level of the small
oval countenance of the child who sat
sedately on the hall chair Barclay noted
with an artist's appreciation the bloom
on her dazzling cheeks the straight nose
the richly scarlet mobile lips he
approved the curling black lashes
finally penciled arching eyebrows sleek
black bobbed hair her creamy silk dress
rather longer than worn by most children
of her age apparently about six was
smoked in a knowing fashion with bright
colors her feet were inappropriately
encased in high-heeled French slippers
all this the artist and Barclay captured
at a glance just as he took in the
beauty of the slender tiny hands of the
taper fingers and the eloquence of every
gesture a strange and unusual child this
his leaping footsteps brought upon him a
lifting of fringed eyelids and what he
felt shrinking Lee was a glance of
indifference he stopped short at the
foot of the staircase abashed at this
disdainful glance he knew all at once
why this child's frock was longer than
customary why her tiny feet were adult
styled footgear why sophistication
animated those taper fingers the cobalt
blue eyes that regarded him from the
child's elfin face were the eyes of a
grown woman
they were the informed eyes of one who
has passed through the fires of varied
experiences the eyes of one who is gazed
unafraid upon unveiled mysteries the
child was not a child but was an
exquisite [ __ ] a creature set apart
from the entire world by her miniature
proportions foster sprang up caught the
other man's hand and drew him down to
the Hasek himself sinking upon the floor
so that both men's faces were below the
level of the midgets Barclay foster said
in a tone of repressed excitement
miscarried or nay permits me to present
you honored miscarried or nay mumbled
Barclay still confused under the keen
gaze of those faintly derisively eyes he
understood it after a minute she was
touched with amusement at his
discomfiture an elfish smile twitched at
one corner of her scarlet lips and she
actually turned away those two shrewd
eyes as if to spare Barclays feelings a
kindly gesture which did not serve to
tranquilize him for there was just a
touch of condescension in her half smile
mr. foster has been showing me these
canvases from your studio she said
slowly in a shrilly sweet voice I would
very much like that snow scene it is
charming if you will tell me the price
Barclays embarrassment vanished here he
could be sure of himself
I would feel honoured if you would
accept it as a proof of my gratitude for
your having come here he began but his
eyes questioned foster you were anxious
to learn the outcome of last night's
plans said miss Cara door neighs high
voice lightly suspended in the bosom of
her frock by a slender platinum chain
was a platinum whistle which she put to
her lips and sounded at once the bearers
of the sedan chair came up the steps and
into the hall holding the chair close to
their mistress like some bright bird so
airy and graceful was her live movement
she seemed to fly from her chair into
the sedan's shelter she waved one tiny
hand the bearers took their light burden
outside slid it into place in the rear
of the waiting automobile they mounted
into the front and the car slipped
noiselessly away down the road be
speaking the many cylinder motor by its
very silence and pow
barclays stared after it amazed
so that strange little thing is your
wonderful Gwen Cara Dorne why didn't you
warn me Foster lighted a cigarette
hastily and began surrounding himself
with smoke
why didn't I because she won't be talked
about she's proud and sensitive she
considers her miniature body the
ultimate of human perfection and won't
permit its comparison with what she
considers our gross bodies and she's
abnormally proud of her brain she has
reason to be I think it is the most
highly developed I've ever known as an
occultist she's the seventh daughter of
a seventh daughter foster broke off
brusque Lee you were anxious to know
about last night
she has forbidden me to divulge details
but I may tell you briefly that Silva
will never again repeat his evil Act he
was there than last night gasps Barclay
incredulous Lee not appropriate persona
but his familiar was already locked in
with us when I bolted the door behind
Gwen and myself
what do you mean Foster sighed
resignedly let's go down to the studio
it's easier to understand when you've
seen things with your own eyes the
telephone rang mrs. hottest enrichen and
answered it an expression of horror
settled on her placid face Manuel Silva
has been found dead with a knife wound
in his throat she called and gave closer
attention to the telephone foster
beckoned Barclay silently and the two
hurried across the barnyard and into the
woods with the key Barclay had loaned
him foster unlocked the padlock
he pushed the studio door open words
seem superfluous spread on the floor lay
a painted canvas figure pinned down by a
knife through its throat the edges of
the canvas were sharply defined as if
just caught out of the painting leaning
against the south wall with a neatly
trimmed vacancy in its center Barclay
stared closed his eyes convulsively
then stared again I couldn't have done
it alone Foster kept repeating in a kind
of feverish excitement she furnished the
power she'd have done it herself but
she's too I mean he corrected himself
hastily he was too tall
Berkeley stared motionless he was
absorbing the details of a bizarre thing
which confirmed him in his hasty
resolution to burn Silva's painting
without delay the empty space in the
painting distinctly outlined a drooping
seated figure the painted canvas shape
lying on the floor pinned down by the
knife through its pallid painted throat
could have filled that vacancy twice
over it was a full-length standing
figure
you